what none of us are doing is two people
are supposed to become one
I want every time
for that to be there so I can do a
technique
I want it every time I don't want it now
and then I want it everything
now I can pick my techniques now can I
but what am I doing different can
anybody see what I'm doing
taking advantage of the voice presenting
you with them I'm meeting him rather
than saying you come over and grab this
so what you're doing is you're doing
that and going nicely out to the side
and going on
he's worked out by now you've been five
minutes into the technique he's worked
out in the best to follow that way
you've got a better training
that happens to us all without us even
knowing it
so what I'm doing differently is I'm
actually saying I'd like you to have
this and he's going oh that life's
quicker than I thought
but they are in contemplating this he
thought oh that arrived quicker than I
thought
so two people are becoming one
because I'm doing my little bit as well
as he's doing his
so every time
I will get the hand I needed
when I go this way
all right so we'll try again
if you go too deep then you're giving up
some of your sanction your awareness
you're coming up too much if you don't
know enough you'll get stuck here and
you'll you'll be starting from a key on
a strong position it's okay but you've
got to do a strong techniques
any plans informed
you've got to meet him halfway
of Y
'all